Kelly wakasa is a perfect example of if
at first you don't succeed try again
after repeatedly hitting rock bottom
Kelly moved to New York City and was
able to build an audience of millions
who watch him push boundaries do the
uncomfortable and make a lot of money in
the process today we're getting an
inside look into the business one of the
most popular vloggers in New York City
discussed the difficulties that come
along the way I was making like a
thousand to two thousand a month and
then I actually tanked then I just
couldn't make any money and to answer
all of the questions that you've been
dying to hear on this episode of
subscribe if you haven't done that
already because we're closing in on 400
000 subscribers so thank you so much and
now let's begin but first we want to
thank our sponsor Creative Juice as a
Creator you're running a business and as
a business you got to have a business
banking account that's separate from all
of your personal stuff well fortunately
Graham Creative Juice is the perfect
place to get started choose funds
creative Futures so that you can stay in
control of your content and supercharge
your growth not only does juice provide
creators with funding it's a One-Stop
shop for all of your creator banking
needs think debit cards with rewards
invoicing team collaboration tools
paying your contractors real-time
analytics and more let juice automate
your business so that you can stay
focused on what matters the most which
is your content and I love that they
also offer funding like their juice
funds refresh and Reserve program that
allows you to get the funding you need
to make the content you want just choose
refresh for your short-term needs or
reserve for up to two million dollars in
funding to grow your business as an
investor induced myself I recognize just
how helpful funding could be juice funds
offers 100 Creator control flexible deal
links starting as short as three months
trust-based relationships easy payouts
and dedicated support from industry
experts you could use these funds to
purchase Studio space hire freelance
help or do anything else that you
believe will help expand the business so
sign up for a free Creative Juice
business banking account today by using
the link Down Below in the description
or by going to getjuice.com getfunding
so get started now and take control of
your creator business once again guys
it's completely free the link Down Below
in the description thank you so much and
on to the podcast look into this camera
say welcome back to the iced poppy hour
welcome back to the ice poppy hour
with me is that what you wanted or
beautiful thank you so much for making
it on the ice poppy hour Kelly we're
excited to be here this is a wicked
house we have to describe where we are I
feel like we're three levels underground
in a bedroom yep it's a basement turn
bedroom and this is uh my roommate
Luke's house or whereabouts his
situation yeah this is a very nice place
like a lot of places in New York are
very small but this is like an actual
large like condo what do you call it I
mean it's like a pretty much a townhouse
I would say I mean we have a backyard so
I feel like that has to be like house
house yeah lovely place you hosted a
boxing event two nights ago that was
crazy it's all just like a YouTube
boxing event with a bunch of people
punching each other in the face you
included yeah I mean I just built a
boxing ring and thought it'd be funny to
have like a fight night in a party and
I'm glad you guys that was like last
minute too I was yeah shocked that we
were like okay we're gonna do this
podcast today we're like actually I got
this bomb boxing match I want to do in
my living room I had decided Friday
night so like the day before I built it
and just because of like scheduling I
was like okay if I'm gonna make this
video happen I have to make it now
because I'm leaving on Thursday yeah and
I want to be like a weekend party
otherwise like no one shows up so and
you built it yourself did you or did you
yeah yeah you did all of the things like
because it's actually like a somewhat
legitimate boxing I mean it's like it's
not like because it's like pool noodles
and stuff like that yeah I love to throw
a b-roll yeah yeah we'll throw up some
footage maybe we wait until you post a
video and we'll you look like you're
itching in the corner just to get in
there part of me wanted to because like
there was there was 20 to me that
thought man I could kick some ass in
this thing oh yeah yeah okay okay
like I saw that the you know people
putting their hands down they didn't
have good form and posture yeah
Alex you want a box
where you at I posted on Instagram I
said like who would you guys like to see
in the iced coffee hour and I made like
this makeshift spreadsheet of how many
times each name was mentioned oh really
yours was mentioned I believe it was
third
uh the first was Casey neistat so it was
Ryan Serhant okay and then it was you
you know okay you know I mean you're
very probably well aware of Casey
neistat is we saw Candace earlier today
that's sweet crazy we saw his wife at
Sweet greens earlier just coincidentally
oh really she was just there and it was
like Hey Candace and she just weirded
out you said hi I wouldn't have said hi
I didn't know what to say she was
walking right by us and I was like wait
a second I noticed anything why would
you call it like I just went hey Candace
that doesn't sound terrible but I didn't
say anything I didn't say like hey I'm a
fan like because we're also planning on
shooting with Casey he was DM and Casey
yeah we were talking about setting
something up when we're here oh nice but
we were pushing it until a little later
and then Jax is hiking and she looked
over like who is this guy I was like
right next time I was talking to Casey
about maybe he's like oh okay but I'm
sure she's like oh he's one of these
guys like you know one of them that's
tens of thousands of people talking to
him on like a weekly basis yeah I've met
Casey I don't know if Casey has met me
like literally I'm like hey what's up
like I saw him on the street once and I
offered to help because he had like
garbage bags and I think he was shooting
a thumbnail at the time
um but I didn't like introduce myself I
was like oh what's up I'm just you need
help and then he just like looked at me
like like this and then we had a um a
lunch at YouTube that we were all
invited just like 10 creators was like
Dr Mike uh Casey Dylan Lemay and myself
and Ashley and then I went up and said
Hi and then he just kind of went around
so yeah
moment he's like the YouTubers YouTuber
like all the YouTubers just like a door
I feel like everyone does so respected
everyone in New York too is like he's uh
yeah he's Casey yeah I mean he just he
walks on water even at the YouTube
office like there's other people in the
room that are definitely like notable
status and then he's just like above and
beyond yeah interesting well we're here
to talk about you oh yeah okay by the
way I realized that I saw your video a
while ago asking oh it was you you asked
out your crush
um like was it Elementary School okay
that's how I initially found you oh
what's that the Middle School Crush
video I'll your editing was so good like
I watched your video and it made me feel
like crap because I want my video
afterwards I'm like my videos suck
compared to like the work that you put
in the storytelling yeah yeah and
they're like
I mean that video specifically was uh I
mean a long time in the making it was
actually we I had shot a video I had a
Duo Channel with my friend Luke where we
like dm'd our Middle School crushes and
so we had all this footage and then I
was like we never met up so I was like
oh my God this would be amazing Let's uh
finally do this and I still kind of had
those butterflies when I made that video
so it's all very genuine and uh I think
the results like kind of showed for
itself that it was a good story well
tell us a little bit about like your
story growing up and and what led you to
here today yeah well I'm from San
Francisco Bay Area uh specifically like
Burlingame area I don't know if you guys
are familiar but yeah grow up grew up
playing soccer and then getting into
YouTube I found a passion for
skateboarding so actually my first
initial 100 000 subscribers are all from
skateboarding content and I worked with
the biggest YouTube skate Channel
Braille skateboarding I don't know if
you guys know him Aaron Cairo Braille
skateboarding
um they have like five million
subscribers I think the ones that they
try different decks yeah yes crazy day I
loved yeah I like the glass and stuff
like that I loved that yeah doing a
kickflip with that so I I was um I was
an intern for them for
many years just like unpaid just like
help do camera work and was just kind of
like a sponge learning how long were you
at the time like 15 16. how'd you get
the position as their intern sent just
like a bunch of emails that I was
honestly surprised they got back to me
you send emails that's exactly what
happened wow just lots of emails that's
cool though that's cool yeah and then
since then just kind of like evolved
content-wise over the years and
now I guess I make
Adventure Vlogs did you know that you
had an interest in YouTube specifically
or was it more so skateboarding I think
over the course of my life uh video
making has always been like at the
Forefront sometimes in the back just
because at one point I was like Head
Over Heels about skateboarding it was
like my girlfriend now just like all day
skate and um but my filmmaking beginning
started when I was like I want to say
eight or nine and I had like made a lot
of videos using my mom's Mac desktop
computer so I have like videos on other
channels that were from 2009 when I was
nine and like just a decade of videos
now that's incredible what did you um
who did you look up to as a kid did you
have any like uh skate influences or
anything I know for me it was uh
what was the guy's name he was in the
first Tony Hawk named Jamie something
oh
well I was thinking j-o-b no I don't
think it's JV I I feel like I know who
you're talking about but I don't want to
slaughter the last name
okay those are definitely some OG's I
wouldn't say like my era but I would say
like growing up I looked up to another
YouTuber named Chris Chan yep you know
him he's a lifestyle vlogger and
skateboarder like I would say pretty
much Pro to a non-skater's eye I guess
or to a skater's eye as well I don't
want a big disrespect him like that I
didn't realize that but um yeah I used
to look up to this guy specifically he
has like a million subscribers and
I remember just like wow his videos are
so cool and now like we're friends which
is crazy still like we'll get food
together and like I still have to like
pinch myself and it's like we're on the
same level now but it doesn't you know I
always kind of look at him or be like so
cool so what point did you decide to
Pivot to your own content like start
your own channel and go that route
when I was like 15.
that's early yeah yeah I was making
YouTube money in I mean not like YouTube
I want to hear how much do they make
back then well it it's hard to tell but
by the end of high school I was making
like a thousand to two thousand a month
that's it incredible yeah in in high
school with like um I want to say like a
hundred thousand subscribers I feel like
that's a little low for a hundred
thousand subscribers but as a high
schooler like as like a job that's right
it depends on the content I would say
right right yeah yeah I mean
at the time I was hyped like no I would
do it for free so I mean it was
definitely like even then I was already
posting like all the time like multiple
times a week like I would say three
times a week a new Vlog kind of I would
say like more David dobrik's style I was
kind of like grabbing from a lot of
people yeah but
yeah I would say like early Beginnings
just like a couple thousand and then I
actually tanked after doing like one to
two thousand then I just couldn't make
any money so what happened
um I switched up my content again and
you know when you build an audience for
something it's like you guys are doing a
podcast right now then all of a sudden
said like okay we're gonna do vlogs like
it might it might not do well and that's
what happened to me because I did
skateboarding so much as that was my
Niche and then I was like no I cut the
skateboarding because I just felt like
it was such a small Niche that I
couldn't grow to the size that I wanted
to and I wanted to not feel like trapped
in a box and then from there I went from
averaging I wouldn't say like
40 to 50K views to like 10K views or
less and then I was just like
yeah that was uh not making any money
and then how old were you at that time I
want to say like 18 19. right as I moved
out that that's when the views dropped
got it and you were going to college
right no I moved um After High School
after graduating high school I moved to
Los Angeles how are you able to afford
La I had saved up up until I was moving
and I want to say I saved up a good good
chunk like twenty thousand dollars how
did you not spend it I feel like it's so
tempting for people in high school you
have like two thousand dollars a month
rolling in how do you control yourself
to save I don't even think I thought
about spending it I kind of think I
liked seeing the money grow okay I was
like oh this is this is awesome and I
want to say like I was very fortunate
growing up like I didn't feel like
um like my family didn't like struggle
to you know have food or like you know
certain nice things so
um I didn't feel like I needed to to
spend and I had everything I needed I
had a skateboard at a car
and I was good I was just borrowing my
mom's car and just like go around and
film and skate yeah how'd you pick La
it's funny the room we're in right now
this is my friend Luke's room I met Luke
when we were in freshman year of high
school we uh sat next to each other and
we're like oh you skate I skate I do
YouTube you do YouTube a little bit we
should move to LA and blow up and this
was kind of like I want to save during
like the Jake Paul the those type of era
vloggers and so we're like we gotta go
to La and so it kind of like manifests
Itself by the end of high school we're
like okay let's move out let's move to
LA and then we shared a studio apartment
in East Hollywood right in front of like
the blue Scientology building yeah and
uh yeah that's that's what we said what
was the plan like no plan no plan
absolutely no plan what'd your parents
think of that I think at by that time my
parents were like Kelly's a wild child
like he's just gonna do whatever he
wants and uh they knew that I was driven
and so I think they just like said oh
he'll figure it out
but yeah I mean I just like losing money
just doing whatever I wanted you moved
to LA you get in place with your friend
you were making at the time like like
you said one to two thousand dollars a
month yeah
right yeah I had never I never did a
brand deal like ever until like maybe
two years ago from today
so I wasn't making any brand money it
was only AdSense and
but luckily our rent was only 650 each
that's not bad at all yeah I mean it was
it was a studio it's really small and
yeah we just rode with that cash and I
had something saved up I actually really
messed up my boy Luke because I was like
Luke you gotta move out you got to come
down to LA and he's like I have no money
saved up and he was also a way smaller
YouTuber
um so we kind of like supported each
other during that time so humble Beacon
and what sort of content were you
creating was this must have been like
2016. no this was 2019 2018 2019. I
moved out I was making literally the
most random content and that's why it
didn't stick looking back and like this
is the most stupid Direction a YouTuber
can make
um I went from like making some high
school Vlog skating to uh
just like clickbait titles and Vlogs and
I still had like good editing like what
it would just be like I can't believe it
like that would be the title I can't
believe it just hoping you know it's
just full lifestyle and in La it'd be
like you know of course would be like a
moving to LA video and then sometimes
I'd go back to my old niche of
skateboard because like I was like oh
this is all I know and so then I would
do a like a I used to do videos like
asking people about skate trivia on the
street which would do well but it was
just jumping around with so much
different content you would you could
watch one video in the next video I post
look like it's out of your guys's video
or something like it could have been it
could have been like a finance Niche
like I was just literally trying it at
the fan even though I had like at the
time like I want to say like 200 000
subscribers 200 000 subscribers yeah
that's a lot of subscribers I think I
knew how to make a video or I knew how
to make a video but I didn't know how to
like cultivate cultivate an audience
it's great yeah so when did you get your
like viral video what what changed was
no viral video it was definitely just a
slow grind like I still feel now that
I'm just like still so beginning
um but like what was the pivot what
changed that like put you on the path to
make the content easy today
actually I had a manager in La who
basically like kind of roasted my
content we had worked really hard me and
my friend Luke on this video together
and we were just like worked for two
weeks on this video and he's just like
yeah it's not good and so it was kind of
like a wake-up call he was just telling
me like you should like do some
storytelling or something I was like
storytelling what do you want me to
narrate I was like that's that's
suicidal like I can't it was just not
part of my style at the time and then I
just started you know writing down like
okay what how can I package a good video
and I was so obsessed with you know just
YouTube in general that I was like
looking at everybody who's really
winning in the space like Casey or Emma
Chamberlain or David dobrik at the time
and I was just like let me just grab a
little bit from each like
I mean I hope that was like Emma
Chamberlain relatability and Casey and I
sent storytelling and David dobrik funny
and I tried to like pile it in and and
then you know maybe like yes Theory
narration and so it kind of started
molding my style and from there I
started doing more videos that were
story based and I think that's kind of
like still the content that has made me
the bigger Creator I am today yeah I
think that's still the style now it
seems that the story style like that
your sort of narration I believe has
really carried forward a lot like even
now those videos are like just as
relevant I think storytelling is just
something that will never go yeah like
good good videos good stories they're
Timeless so how do you how do you start
with telling a story like is there a
structure that you follow every time or
how do you know like
how to tell it I guess is like how do
you figure this out it's practice it's
got to be practice like this is all I do
every day since I was like sure but walk
us through like just let's say you come
up with a story what's the the
storyboarding I suppose process of like
getting it all out on like a script or a
paper nowadays it's very different than
when it like back in the day nowadays I
think I'm just smarter with YouTube that
I have to start with thumbnail title
like the idea of like what do I want to
look like and then work backwards from
there because I just don't even feel
like wanting to make the video if I know
it's just gonna flop there's so many
cool ideas out there that just don't
work in a thumbnail title that I just
would not make like give us an example
let's let's hear it
maybe we help you on this I mean even
not not nice out loud like that could be
cool
um
we would like I would do a lot of videos
that were just like maybe kind of like a
stunt or something but it didn't like
you couldn't capture the moment in a
thumbnail that was like digestible if
that makes sense
um like we would do videos like in the
LA River like wakeboarding the LA River
I thought this was a great idea or
somehow taking that and elevating that
idea but we can never get it that like
it would go viral and so I feel like
there are certain videos that are very
cool as segments that lead to a bigger
idea that uh that is why like I just
stray away from those ideas if that
makes sense but when you're telling a
story how do you script it how do you
figure out like this is a good hook
this is what people care about
and remove the fluff I think I like to
film and everything happens in post I'll
have a brief like okay let's shoot at
certain places and then just let the
like magic of being out and about
filming happen so you know the best
moments happen when they're like
unscripted obviously if I scripted
everything like the videos would suck
um so I I think I just use like notion
and I just literally like write down
like okay this is you know a checklist
of like things I want to shoot that day
and the next day if I don't get it then
I'll just go out and shoot something
else that comes to mind and a lot of
times I'll have these ideas that'll sit
in my notion or whatever for for months
I think my videos are heavily like you
need an edit like yeah I'm not
jidion or Danny Duncan who's like just
you know naturally super funny and like
that type of content I I would say I'm
closer to like I don't know a Casey
neistat or yes Theory or something that
has more post-production work not to
like say that no no no no no no no so
I've I've hung out with Danny a few
times yeah he is the exact same off
camera exactly like he will do the same
things yeah off camera and I'm like dude
you're not even filming this it's just
he just finds it funny yeah like all the
time of course so it's just like just
filming his life it's wild I thought
honestly he played up for camera but no
that's so funny yeah not at all do you
know who fedias is yes he's the exact
same on camera as he has off camera he's
like a he's honestly a public nuisance
when I go out it's like it's like in a
lovely like yeah yeah like he will like
we'll just be in a restaurant he'll just
like start like yelling not yelling but
like basically just like being a
distraction everybody and he just
doesn't care like yo you realize that
we're not filming right now he's like
yeah no he hog deal on mosque you see
that I did see that I've made be so
happy to see him how many days was he
out there it was like two months was it
almost three wow a month like work in
between that or is that that's it just
uh he was like doing daily shorts that
was a nice thing yeah blew up on YouTube
and Tick Tock by doing the daily shorts
Elon musk's office and I'll tell you
like I honestly felt around day 45 uh he
wasn't gonna do it because he upset Elon
musk's mom someone said he should reach
out to Elon musk's mom and like he
mentioned something to his followers and
everyone went to her and like started
spamming her of like how do they have
your son hog phidius you know and such a
YouTuber thing like I want to hug Elon
Musk for my video so people spam them up
but she was so upset over that that she
did like a public tweet and yeah told
like Elon do not hug him whoa and I was
like oh yeah then that's not gonna
happen especially with security issues I
thought it might set the precedent that
like Elon is now gonna hug anybody who
like camps out for 100 days or something
like that
might set like the wrong tone or he
might say like hey I'll do it but like
you can't post about it we'll do it like
something like that I was worried about
it but the fact that he stayed just as
dedicated like his inspirational to me
that like seriously you would love to
see Graham stuff and like outside of
Casey United States
just give me a hug I don't know someone
like Elon Musk is like that is like the
top tier I was shocked that it is
dedicated he did it though like made me
so happy yeah I mean that's got to be
one of the hardest people to reach yeah
so I just did it
resilience right there so when for you
did things on YouTube really start
taking off to the point where like okay
now you're affording a nicer place you
moved to New York right yeah I would say
2020. 2020 was an hour is kind of like
the change I I would say like when I
felt like I was making it was when I was
averaging 100 000 views I was like oh my
God this is all I ever wanted 100 000
views and that happened in the summer of
2020 and that was just through like
the new style of content I was making
and then from there I actually enrolled
in college after being out of college
for two years because I saw the
opportunity to go to college to make
videos going to college to make videos
yes so being a college YouTuber yeah at
the time I noticed like all these
college videos do so well and they're no
offense like kind of like I was like
What if I go to college and I just make
videos but I don't even focus on school
like I'll make great videos what college
videos are doing well even just a basic
Day in the Life anything yes the day in
the life of a UCLA student kept getting
recommended the Harvard The Ivy Leagues
yeah the day in the life of uh
car you know what was the one there's
John was it John fish yeah John fish
yeah yeah I mean just at the time yes I
think I mean I think even today like
college content is still very like you
know that's the everyone who's on
YouTube is like kind of younger and
wanting to go to college or like wants
to see especially like even UCSB like I
think they have like uh 30s no they have
they have a ton of students but I know
each year when people want to go and
join UCSB or they want to apply there
they have like hundreds of thousands of
applicants very high likelihood that
those people are going to watch day in
the life of a UCSB student yeah so like
all of those like still pop off even for
schools what college did you want to go
to what was the plan well
originally in high school I applied to
colleges but by the end of high school I
just didn't want to go but I didn't get
in so I couldn't go gone anyway
um so I applied to the University of
Arizona which I knew I could get in
because it's like a 95 acceptance rate
and so I went to University of Arizona
really yeah because I knew at the time
um this sounds bad but like I knew they
they didn't really care about covid like
they just like they had very little
rules there so I could like kind of
still film and it was like kind of
maskless and like I'm not I'm not like
an advocate for that but Florida had
been just as good like don't more people
go to Florida probably yeah I just being
on the west coast and from like the Bay
Area like so when people went to Arizona
and like I was kind of familiar and I
also knew that they love to party and I
thought like oh my God this is great
content like I have so many ideas so
from like all this momentum I had that
summer I was like okay now I'm going to
college and then from there that's I
think the year because I was in college
for a year that really like solidified
my presence as a YouTuber and like had a
community by then and you moved to
Arizona and like lived there in Tucson
did you actually study and like do
classdoor was it purely
failing all of my classes so I was I
stayed for a year but I only did one
semester I did a semester and it was
kind of like hybrid online in person and
yeah I had like a 1.8 GPA but by like
two months and I just like stopped
showing up and I was just filming but
what about tuition so so it was kind of
like a business experience it was a
business expense yeah kind of like I was
like okay let's
let's just do it wow
and it was kind of a risk like oh it's
kind of expensive like I think it was
like 14 000 for a semester and I was
like well I always wanted to go to
college if I'm ever gonna go it's got to
be now before I'm like too old and I was
like old I mean I was like 20 year old
freshman I was like oh this is kind of
weird like oh what's up I'm 17 like oh
God like get away kind of thing um God
someone don't clip that
that's like the opening
um
but
yeah even when I was at College I wanted
to like let's just maximize and maximize
so we would film I would edit everything
in my dorm like living with another
student serious yeah so I was doing the
full thing so were you like the 20 year
old guy gets roomed with like the
Freshman or
say 19. I mean I was maybe 19 20 20 or
something but he the guy I ruined with
was 19. okay all right I mean he was
never there so okay but yeah I wanted to
do the full thing and like document
everything
yeah now was it easy to get into like
anywhere because you had the YouTube
channel like I feel like any frat if you
say like hey I got a channel I'll put it
on the channel you guys will get like
way more exposure no no they the frats
don't want me to film anything because I
mean they do like things that they
shouldn't do you know it's like amazing
like hazing or something I mean I would
never say that my frat haste right come
on that's against the rules oh okay
against the Brotherhood I'm just kidding
um but what would they do like I I never
went to college I never
got any college experience like what
what goes down yeah honestly my uh frat
that I joined was called Sigma Alpha mu
uh it was really chill like they were
really like if you ever want to say no
you can just say no so I remember we
would do
like smoothie night which is basically
they would like blend anything put it on
the ground you eat it and wait
[Music]
I don't get that it was just like let's
do stupid stuff to make their lives hell
you know for entertainment for
entertainment for them and looking back
I'm not gonna lie maybe like it's not
everyone's cup of tea for sure yeah but
like the guys I did it with you build
such a bond it's almost like going to
war I mean I've never been to war it's
like I don't know but I'm guessing uh
but one of the funniest things we did
was we had a courtyard and then they had
just like these cups they had um a
garbage can one corner and a garbage can
the other one was full of water one was
not and they all gave us a spoon and so
while they were like pelting us with
like water balloons and tomatoes or
whatever we had to put all the water
from one garbage can in the other using
spoons while like tied to everybody and
it was just hilarious just hilarious
that sounds fun see that's something I
know for a fact I would love yeah yeah
Graham come on let's do a video going
back to college finally or something
Grant I went back to college that would
be a great idea I would do one day
oh business yeah I want to do going back
to an MBA program for one day at an Ivy
League that would be good I would do
college for a day honestly I would
that'd be a good I try it
yeah well then we have to do if you're
gonna do that you also have to do like
the the gnarly frat version too because
I mean that's what people are going to
want to see like interest just that
reaction is priceless come on
I just feel like guys it's stupid like
why are we doing this
I'd be like starting a lemonade stand
you're like so let's raise money for
something you want to start lemonade No
One's Gonna buy lemonade
I don't think I looked 32. I think if I
went on a college campus I could blend
in perfectly I mean there's a whole
range of students too yeah you could be
like a graduate student sure or
something yeah okay
yeah what else did they do like what was
the I mean there's like drinking
shotgunning
keg standing
I'm trying to think there is definitely
a lot of interesting we never did like
an elephant walk or something weird
how's that
do you know I don't know oh God I don't
know an elephant walk an elephant uh
this is like the gnarliest of gnarly
frat things I've also like feel like now
I'm branding myself as a Frack I was
only there for a semester guys
um but you're the one with the
experience
you didn't go to college I went to UCSB
and I dropped out oh okay but you never
know frat no no Elephant Walk is like oh
God I can't even explain this oh if the
Frat guys watches you're like dude it's
like the gnarly thing I've never done
I'm not okay but it was like word around
town like one frat did it which
basically is like you get in the line
behind your frat mates or whatever and
to me this is really sucks like you put
your thumb in their butt and then you
hold their their elephant in the back no
way
yeah I would question whose idea that
was in the first place
oh my gosh
iced coffee hour Elephant Walk bonding
wow
[Laughter]
hey all right I just don't know what I
expected I thought I knew it was like
alcohol or something that's what I
thought too just nothing to do without
them yeah
you guys never partook no it was never a
actual thing
Now Grant is excited to go to college
he's yeah he's ready to go oh man all
right sign me up I'm still fitting we
have the red Solo cups too just water
guys it's just water
during that same year I brought on like
my first employee which was like huge
for me and yeah I felt like okay like I
have an audience I have a routine I have
a brand and it was at the same time
where I actually came up with um or no
it was earlier but it was really strong
that like my fans knew me as like my
slogan do what excites and basically
like people were like having this
community with this catchphrase kind of
thing can you explain what that means do
what excites was something I made up
when I was at like my lowest point in my
life when I was just like super lonely
like borderline depressed just felt like
YouTube wasn't gonna work out and this
was
honestly right right before the summer
where things started to pick up I was uh
living in between places in between like
my first La apartment in my second La
apartment and so it was like a two or
three month period where I was like
living at my grandma's in La just felt
like I'm making no money I just feel
like such a loser and I just was like in
this cycle of sadness and I couldn't
like get myself to do anything I'd go to
the gym and that was pretty much it
never felt like the camera like what I
was filming was good enough because
nothing was working up into that point
and
yeah I wrote down one day like what's my
favorite emotion out of pure like
I'm nothing I have literally nothing so
I might as well write something down and
I didn't want to write down like
happiness or something because I felt
like that was didn't mean anything to me
and I wrote down excitement and I
literally don't remember but I somehow
came up with doing excites at that time
and I was like I'm just going to do what
excites every single day and maybe
that'll help and I use that like phrase
as like motivation every day and said in
every single video and literally just
like changed my life as like just a
mantra to look in my mirror and be like
you're gonna do what excites every day
so what were some of those first steps
like what excites in those in that
situation that you were in I mean I
think everyone defines it differently
like you know whoever watched the video
might be like oh do any size I'm gonna
jump out of an airplane or something but
I know to me what was like exciting and
kind of like okay I'm pushing myself
every day to like go after it so I guess
it could be like skydiving or overcoming
your fears or something like that and
that Mantra kind of pushed you through
to this next level and now you have a
whole brand do what excites and yourself
merch and everything like that yeah and
it was kind of like kind of like oh
discovering who I am and what do I want
to push because I always wanted to push
something positive and I never had like
a catchphrase or something that I really
could stand behind and so that was like
kind of a big moment I think just for my
brand like personal branding online
um so ever since I had that I kind of
like okay let's just write out do what
excites and hey this is what what type
of video should I make this week I
should do what excites that's the most
exciting thing that you've done most
exciting thing that I've done well a
video that's coming out well I don't
know when this comes out might have been
out already but I spent 24 hours with
the world's tallest man in turkey and to
me it was just like so hard to get this
it was such a risk that it was so
exciting to me so I feel like this is
one of those doing exciting moments in
rare life moments that I got to have and
like super grateful to have flew to the
middle of nowhere in Turkey right near
the Syrian border and met up with the
world's tallest man on his farm spent
all day like going around with him and
yeah it was just like just a while how
did you get in contact with them I just
dm'd uh his manager that was inspired
yeah and then I and it's not it wasn't a
free collab so I had to pay uh his
name's Sultan yeah to uh spend the day
together and uh I just like you know
this year I'm like I want to take the
next level like whatever I don't care
about money yeah sorry Graham wouldn't
he I'm just curious now because I'm
trying to think here wouldn't you want
the extra exposure like the fact that he
gets like a dedicated video from you I
think uh this is how he makes his money
oh God because he doesn't have like a
social presence as much so he does all
of his mod like you know his salary or
whatever money he's making is just
through appearances can I ask how much
it was to spend the day with him yeah um
so originally his fee just for like two
to three hours was four thousand dollars
US dollars US Dollars whoa and so I was
like I I'd seen other videos he had done
with other YouTubers and I was like ah
they're just kind of like showing him as
a spectacle so I was like I want to do
24 hours like I want to spend a whole
day and see what his life is really like
because it's kind of crazy to be like
he's eight four he's eight four eight
four
and so yeah to spend all day I paid him
eight thousand dollars so there's
probably not a return on investment but
I was like walk us through that now I'm
so curious so like how long did it take
to get there like what was your first
impression when you met him do you like
Paul was but like does he speak English
or like how did you guys communicate
does he speak it so we brought a
translator okay and he spoke I would say
like decent English I mean most
questions I asked him we had to use a
translator but as soon as I saw him he's
like Kelly
I love America I love America and I
would ask some questions about like
random things like coffee he's like I
love iced coffee you Mike says iced
coffee hour
random things and yeah we had breakfast
we went shopping we played like Turkish
games it seemed like a small town so
it's not like you can go out and like
everybody already knows who he is so
they're not like oh my gosh he's a tall
guy because I already know who he is I
think like a big part of turkey knows
who he is oh wow so his town is not tiny
where he lives is like on his farm
outside of the big town so we went to
the big town and it was like BTS like
everyone was pulling up to see him we're
in a tiny store in the middle of nowhere
boom 20 people out of nowhere and taking
pictures like hugging him and like
giving him tea is or they know who he is
or it's like I don't know the language
so I couldn't tell like okay are they
just taking it because he's a spectacle
or I think they also knew who who he was
okay but everywhere we went it was like
I don't know like BTS Like every like
tons of people coming through how old is
he 40. and does he have like trouble
with mobility and stuff oh yeah so he
was using me as like a cane and so he's
using you yeah he would I mean it was
really cool I mean I was like he would
put all of his body weight on me and he
also had one crutch that he would use
and then we'd walk around
what does he do if you like if you
weren't there how would he always has
someone so he was just like for for our
video using me as his person kind of
thing so if it wasn't you it'd be
another person who's always with him as
a yeah okay just to get around why a
person and not uh like a like a cane or
something on the other side you know I
never I didn't ask him that okay so yeah
I was curious too he only has one cane
like maybe just get two or something I I
don't really know but it seems like a
person yeah it's like a very because
important thing and but not only that
but you have to be the right height of
person like if like I don't know if I
would be good yeah I don't know yeah
like that like you have to be the right
size to do it I mean I didn't get all
the info out of him I have to go back I
didn't ask him like that did you ask if
he could do a standing dunk he can he
can I also without jumping he can just
dunk it he can dunk it wow and I asked
my Instagram like what do you guys want
to know about the world's tallest man
and everybody was like how big is his
penis
and so I asked him
and and then I don't think he understood
so we still don't know
but then but did the translator
understand or like yeah so that it was
funny because uh yeah because one I was
like I don't I don't I didn't feel that
comfortable asking him like Hey that's
weird it's a weird question like dude
it's like so personal like no one says
it right and so I asked him uh for when
this video comes out like can you like
get angry or something at the question
and he's like just was so like loving to
film and like happy go lucky that he's
like sure and I had brought from my
house a breakaway bottle so I asked him
like how big is your is your penis and
then he just hit me with the bottle it's
just like it's just a funny moment I'm
curious is this furniture in the house
larger to fit his size okay as bad as I
would say like double the size of a
normal bed in length but besides that
his like
ceilings are low his I was like how are
you not like catering to yourself you
know uh he's literally ducking under his
door and I'm like are you kidding me
you're like the world's tallest man I
didn't imagine like 4 000 American to
see him like he's that's gonna be a ton
of money for his location yeah and like
he could buy a house probably like just
every now and then he has like a few
pairs of shoes like lid just sits on the
ground and but I think he's happy I
don't think you know don't need too much
let's go back to you to your time uh in
college when you started like I said
like that really meteoric ride just
wants to know about the elephant I don't
want to know more about you check out
this video
how um how much were you making at the
time if you're able to say uh I think at
the time
I was just getting my foot in the door
with brand deals
but that was really inconsistent
so in college I
maybe if like
I don't even probably like five to ten
thousand a month that's good maybe
that's kind of I'm kind of guessing but
I'm pretty sure
I could be wrong that's very comfortable
living extremely comfortable living in
college yeah especially the Frat doesn't
know but I moved into the second
semester and they never charged me so it
was cool they never charged it yeah they
never charged why did they charge you I
think because I moved in second semester
and everyone was like long-term living
so I got lucky there too why didn't you
continue at College I didn't feel as
satisfied like okay I knew this door is
going to close and I was just like I
feel ready to move on the content was
getting a little repetitive and I wasn't
a student I just felt like that wasn't
me I thought I thought it was really fun
for that year but uh I was just ready
like hey let's why don't I get ready for
like actual life and build the content
that's gonna sustain me like for more
years than if I build myself so much as
a college vlogger and then like as soon
as College ends like what do I do like
what do I do and so I kind of wanted to
always make sure that I wasn't making
only College videos and I could like you
know make videos that I could make after
college and how did you notice that
transition uh with your own success like
what was it positively uh responded to
when you didn't go to college it was
hard yeah I think I the audience I had
which I would say like averaged like 200
000 views per video during college or or
more and after that the content for me
was hard to make because I was so like
all my friends are here I have you know
filmer lives in Arizona and the things
were rolling I had you know the jokes
with the certain campuses like oh just
make a college video like it's super
easy and so after it was a little bit
more of rediscovering and I also just
like bumping around place to place
because I didn't want to sign a lease
just somewhere random so there was
probably a good five months I was just
like what am I doing so another like
damn like not rock bottom just like what
am I doing like is this it again how do
you figure out a way around that just
keep showing up and then eventually we
moved uh three other friends to New York
City so from college I moved to New York
City last year which was your mom's
house which is like a Creator house that
we had last year what was the motivation
behind doing a Creator house I had
always wanted to live in Creator house I
felt like
you know those were like the people I
love spending time with because like we
have such a shared passion and so I was
like literally willing to do whatever it
takes to like end up in a crater house
because you know you know content
creation can be really lonely and
my my whole like where I was really
struggling was because I was so alone
feeling that uh I just wanted to be
around Creator so I was like we'll do it
whatever it takes you know cold calling
meeting up with people like oh you're a
Creator like let's meet up and try to
make something happen so you decided to
go with the Creator house here in New
York City and did you notice that the
Creator house positively affected your
success as a YouTuber and was it like
drastic if so of course I mean I
wouldn't say it's drastic because like
fuse probably went from like
250k to like maybe like 400k that's
that's pretty substantial but like I
feel like also like look back like some
of my videos would do that or like more
or something so it was just like
building that audience and definitely
there was more um eyeballs because like
yeah we have three people that were
always collaborating with and yeah I
can't say that didn't help like we were
making videos all together building a
brand together and everybody was looking
forward to our videos every single week
and would be like okay I'm gonna watch
uh Elliot's video and then Emery's video
then Kelly's video then Ashley's video
so it was like really it's cool like
sitcom where you get to see yeah
perspectives like it's cool it reminds
me of like the the David David dobrik
thing yeah like everyone in their own
like perspective content and then and
everybody came in with the audience so
it's kind of like we're just like
yeah you guys know the Critter house and
just constantly collabing but now you're
in this spot and the last house was it
just ended yeah uh I mean it's like
pretty public like just just didn't end
well and it was a lot we had
some differences and I think we're in
the beginning we were just like very
naive and didn't look at the big picture
of things we just like literally put
four strangers together almost like
expecting it to work in like day one
started like making videos together and
yeah we just at the end just didn't
renew the lease and everyone went kind
of like separate ways what were some of
the differences I would say like just
the level of like how much they love
YouTube and want to do that forever kind
of thing I think some certain people
just like wanted different things out of
YouTube and content creation and also
like different rates of how much they
can work like me I could like literally
film all day every day and just like
that's like where I get my energy where
I think a lot of people like hey I need
to like take days off or just like not
film for a week or two I think there was
always this like
balance of filming and not filming so
I think I mean obviously like crater
houses do work but just this one didn't
work Andrew so the difference in
business perspectives and you said that
when you guys initially moved in
together like it was nearly strangers so
there was no like real conversation
beforehand of course there was cons like
a conversation right right sure
conversations but but uh but like
hanging out with each other like getting
to know each other yeah so like I was
really good friends with Elliot so like
that was like a solidified relationship
but Emery and Ashley were pretty like I
didn't know Ashley really I had met
Anne-Marie before and so that was kind
of like
you know uh you know I knew one person
really well and then the rest were kind
of like we're like gonna learn about
each other interesting yeah and then
from there basically the after the end
of the lease you guys decided to to come
get this spot over here and uh it's
similar it's a kind of a Content house
right yeah I think we just learned from
the last one like hey let's just all do
our own thing we still live together as
creators so it's kind of like we have
co-workers and also just like friends I
mean literally everyone who lives in
this house now just like we're just
friends like we barely even filmed
together we just like hang out um
but yeah it is similar I guess in the
last one what are some of the key
takeaways like things that you learned
from the first content house that you
had I think you have to look really big
picture when you're building like a
business with other people so a lot of
times there's so many cooks in the
kitchen everyone has different ideas
it's really hard when there's four
people coming up with one solution so I
guess like in the future I would just be
like
one just do it myself or maybe like one
partner or
something like that I'm trying to think
I really would never have changed
anything like it was a great time I
think everyone who was involved like had
like you know such a crazy experience
that we'll all remember and laugh about
in a few years
so do you wish you could have made it
work I mean we definitely tried to make
it work and it was like almost like a
relationship like with a girlfriend or
boyfriend and
I think we're just really trying and if
not everyone is trying it kind of can't
work and
we had a whole year to keep keep growing
and we had everything was working like
exterior I guess if that makes sense
like online everything was totally
working
but I think as a just a community and
like hey are we going to invest the next
you know five years of Our Lives to try
to build this to be like a sidemen
because we're really looking at all
these other content collectives like hey
can we do this as well interesting so
you saw it as kind of building a
business with other people not so much
as like yo we're all going to move in
together and just kind of film content
around each other and then that's that
no no I totally thought it was just for
filming content the business I was at
the end oh is that just kind of not was
a byproduct of everyone living yeah we
never made any money together it was all
individual channels so we were just all
filming together but by the end it was
kind of like okay should we
because we had already like from the
beginning like we can make group Channel
videos it'd be so fun to like make group
videos just send it to an editor it's
not like someone's baby just be like
yeah because everyone's so creatively
different but by the end then that's
where there was talks of like okay well
if we renew if we kind of like Stay
Together kind of do this thing like
let's do it or don't kind of thing
and that's when a lot of things just
like went downhill and then it was just
like okay this is not happening
interesting but now here at this place
it's it's like uh I would say it's not
so much you're seeing it as like a
business it's more so like what you had
initially in mind where everybody has
their own like videos and it's just kind
of like hanging out with each other and
shooting content like that we're
literally just roommates and then like
if we want to be like yo can you help me
get a shot well yeah I'll help you get a
shot or like get a you know if you want
me in your video or something but the
last one I never saw like really like
that business minded because I'm really
not business minded at all like I'm just
like I'm just gonna make the video so
like every week just make the videos but
here it's just like
like it's just my roommate and then we
happen to be friends as well one thing
that I noticed about your content and I
know most people probably wouldn't label
it this way but it could kind of be
described as like like self-help or
development right because you you talk
about like how to not give an f sure or
like how to not care about certain
things and also like body transformation
stuff as well yeah which I found kind of
interesting how do you learn to not give
an f or to care
well I have a great video for you to get
my video
synopsis
recommendations or uh no I I think I
actually watched that video but yeah I
mean yeah like it's a
to me it's a repetition thing it's a
practice thing and I think it's an
identity thing I think if you kind of
like in my in the beginning it might be
hard to you know just not if you're
really not confident and then be like
I'm confident it is a slow you know not
an overnight thing but I do think like
you know confidence is a choice and I
say that because everyone can you know
go to the gym can work on themselves
everybody can read or work harder on
their business or anything so
I think in that video and when I was
trying to convey was just you know one
and you know Inspire hopefully but just
tell my story because I didn't actually
the video title is how not to give a f
but really it just tells my story of how
I learned and I was just sharing my
experience rather than telling you how
you have to do it because I because I
don't know how how to tell Graham to not
give an f or you know it's just like I
only know what I know how'd you learn
practice I would say practice and like
consistently going out of my comfort
zone and becoming the person that I want
to be kind of like writing down hey if I
want to be at or not athletic because
that's like kind of like genetics or
whatever but like hey I want to have a
good body that I feel comfortable in
that like this is what I like or I want
to make this amount of money so I don't
feel like insecure with that like it's
like I think just like kind of like
working on those maybe insecurities or
things that I feel less confident about
and in that journey of like trying to
get confident I think is where I learned
that like where you're
was already you could be confident with
it why do you think it's important or in
what situations do you think it is
important to not give an f i mean I
think you know living life with a bunch
of other people's thoughts about you in
mind is a really limited life and if
you're always constantly thinking about
what people will perceive you as like
you're just gonna live a less fun life
and I know from experience like I used
to be like out in public you know
filming like oh my God is someone
looking at me or then I I remember like
literally developing a stutter because I
would get nervous of filming be like
what's up guys
um but you know after so many years like
now I can smoothly say what's up guys
like you know in front of you know
anybody or something not that I actually
say what's up guys what's up guys it's
Graham here so it's just like literally
just through repetitions and practice of
getting out of your comfort zone
sometimes just challenging challenging
yourself to to do weird and crazy things
that you wouldn't normally do out in
public or whatever sure yeah I think
that is one one way and
to you might be different like whatever
your insecurities are or things that you
need to tackle in order to feel like 100
confident that you don't give an f is
what you should do like you know if you
want to do a Consulting call I could you
know
four thousand two hours I need to make
up my money what
um what are you insecure about now
that's a great great opportunity great
question go straight open
um I mean I've even said it on my
channel oh no this is like that's not
what I'm insecure that was like old
insecurity
um I would say
now I'm just like really like can I can
I take this to the next level with my
YouTube I just feel like I'm still a
small Creator and I think I'll kind of
always have this insecurity of like am I
good enough am I funny enough am I good
enough at editing or storytelling and I
think that's just because a comparison
is kind of a you know the thief of joy
in that sense where you see everybody
online you see iced coffee hour pulling
numbers and you go what what am I doing
you know and so yeah I think that's
something that I'll always have in the
back of my mind like
just uh maybe it's a little bit of
competitiveness and also insecurity of
like I want to be one of the better
YouTubers sometimes insecurities and
beliefs like that can serve you which in
this case it sounds like it kind of is
it's like a big motivator for you yeah
I'm pretty like
straight to the point with myself like a
lot of people be like oh like positivity
like oh you should look in the mirror
and be like you're gonna you're amazing
person you're so awesome but I I kind of
like to look at him and you're like
you're fat as [__] you did nothing today
and so that kind of gets my like getting
it going gets me going a little bit more
but you know everyone's different I
don't expect everyone to be like David
Goggins or something what was your old
insecurity body was definitely one I was
a little chubby when I was little and my
family was like super athletic like all
my siblings went D1 soccer and my mom is
like also a soccer player so like me
being chubby I was like looking to my
left and right like damn y'all got six
packs like I got the bakery and so that
was definitely one of my first uh
insecurities that I wanted to
you know I guess conquer and that's like
an endless grind obviously I got a
couple a what a couple of insecurities
uh yeah uh my first one was body hair I
just have copious amounts of body hair
I'm walking like gorilla yes awesome
it's everywhere man you're playing it's
there uh but I would say that was
probably like my biggest insecure no but
no I think the one that I thought was
silly was I think with the face oh yeah
asymmetrical face I don't see it well
that's because you're you're saying it
you don't have a symmetrical face yes
and a lot of people don't do you see it
of course he sees it I mean people is
that the first thing you noticed when
you saw Jackson yeah it was I didn't
want to say it stop
well first of all you have great face
yeah you did you guys all have great
faces we all have great faces
but to say it's not symmetrical I mean I
don't know I don't even notice it it
doesn't like yeah that but that's
because
a lot of people don't notice people's
insecurities exactly why they're so
confident already you know I think that
it's funny because someone pointed this
out to me it's like if you walk into a
Starbucks and you open up the door for
the Starbucks and somebody's like kind
of far and you're like okay am I gonna
hold it open for them yeah and then
you're like okay I'm not going to and
then you rush in but then they kind of
like did a quick leap to try to like get
in the door you know what I mean like
you're gonna be thinking about that for
the next day but they are gonna forget
about it in two minutes so a lot of the
times the point here is that you
remember your own faults and things are
such a big deal to you when to other
people it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter that's true I also always say
that you're not that special I always
tell myself you're not that special like
no one cares like you could fall and
like pour milk all over yourself and
people forget in two seconds like you
just said no one cares you know I saw
short on that either it was a YouTube
video or something like that where a guy
was like just to prove that point yeah
like I think you like I forget what he
did he did something so crazy in public
like nuts with he's running on his
underwear like screaming or something
like covered in oil people were just
walking by like wouldn't even look well
that's yeah I feel like they definitely
noticed it yeah thinking about that too
for them they told their friends yeah
but my point being it's like no one
stopped him no one laughed like just
people were just like minding their own
business and kept like walking by yeah
just no one paid a minute yeah but I do
see those tick tocks of those that guy
as well people don't care about what you
do oh yeah I like this like oh I could
just walk up here and I can stand on
this park bench and I can say hello to
this stranger I love this videos because
he's like you can control your own
reality yeah and you could do whatever
you want just look it's I think it's so
cool yeah I mean yeah yeah I would say
that's like a similar message to do what
excites or anything kind of just like
hey Propel you know my audience to just
like hey you could do whatever you want
create your own reality reality and just
like live the life that you want pretty
much
let's bring up the topic of income real
quick a good question we ask a lot of
the guests is if you were to create a
pie and assign a value to each slice in
the pie what would your income look like
on that pie so like sources basically
okay
um AdSense brand deals merchandise are
definitely the biggest and then maybe a
little bit of affiliates
so is that like 30 30 10. it's like no I
would I would say brand deals is
definitely the biggest chunk then
AdSense and merch is very similar so I
would say those like would be almost
a third a third a third but I would say
brand deals is
maybe half the pie
interesting so brand deals is probably
your your largest income Source yeah
Brands pay a lot of money what sort of
brands are you getting I just did one
with like
Samsung
you did one with Samsung yes Samsung
who's bringing you these deals uh
just well I have a management yeah um I
used to be with select woohoo we're
great and then I'm now with Whaler okay
and yeah they're both great management
and yeah we've been
you know nor vpn's very casual sponsors
on YouTube or I'm trying to think who
else that are like because they're great
Brands better help
there's a good amount what other cool
ones I feel like I've had some cool ones
I feel like Brands really like your
content because it's very positive I I
hope so yeah that'd be awesome
I mean yeah this is wholesome wholesome
content you know it makes you feel
better when you watch it well thank you
yeah thank you so for the future what
excites what are the plans
I'm just gonna dive and put my head down
with the videos I'm doing and making
sure like I'm investing 100 effort into
them and I think
the end result of that will
be awesome I guess and that's and what's
the desired end result or is it just
right now it's just focusing in and just
having fun with the content making yeah
I think like I honestly could care less
about the money or
anything besides just like let's make
bangers like let's literally just make
the best videos we can and that's really
what like feeds me as just like a person
like even the boxing thing with
something that's like well that's kind
of extra like I don't have to do that I
probably could just do a day in the life
video but I'm like kind of tired of that
I'm like that's not pushing myself so
just like the world's tallest man video
like that's like my new standard like I
just want to go on crazy adventures and
document them and tell like the best
story I can seems like a like a yes
Theory except for your perspective yeah
just from my perspective I would say
it's very cool I'm waiting for that
collab yes Theory Amar he's you want to
collab with them yeah we know him on the
podcast you know yeah Mars great
um I invited him actually to the world's
tallest man it's like you should come
but he couldn't at the time I'm just
curious about you guys and how you guys
run the podcast and everything and this
is probably out online but I don't know
do you have you don't do a podcast right
you I don't do it I did have one though
with the uh oh yeah we did have one yes
with uh your mom's house yeah do you
plan on starting one at some point in
the future
um not really yeah I think I'm just
better at making videos rather than
talking
I'm just okay at talking I think we're
still trying to figure out the podcast
to be honest with you we don't know what
we're doing and uh we're trying to get
better at it we realize we have a lot of
shortcomings here yeah and a lot of
things could be improved Jack
so um
so we're still learning so yeah like
even us coming to New York was like an
experiment to see like what it's like to
travel for guests yeah it's just
sustainable do we like it yeah I think
it's very clear in like day one we like
it so we want to do this more it's a big
hill to climb yeah like I mean and also
just like you guys together I always
think like you know you guys both live
in Vegas right yeah and then you know
what if you guys move or something you
kind of stay together you just got to
stay together yeah well I was living
with uh I moved in with him in La that's
where we started the podcast and then
like right after I went full time with
him and dropped out of college he was
like all right I'm moving to Vegas I'm
like well looks like I'm moving to Vegas
yeah so and that's you know big to know
but I feel like you guys could always
but you know what I wouldn't have moved
if you weren't 100 aboard and Macy was
not 100 of course not this guy looks
after me he's a great guy but of course
I wasn't about it just like drop out and
be like all right I'm going all in in
the rejection we talked about it for a
while my dude are you into this idea
would you do it
um are you open to trying it out and I
think we both went in with the mindset
like we could try it for a year like the
worst case if we hate it we could always
change but like give it a year and we'll
know pretty quick and same thing with
Macy it was like we could we could try
it out see if we like it yeah pretty
immediate I think we liked it so it
worked out but yeah it had it been like
the sucks we could always just go back
yeah yeah and I have a question too you
know I feel like a lot of your branding
online is very like
I would say maybe like on an extreme and
like penny pinching a little bit is that
true like is that very like you like
like today what have you spent today
oh I was I was good today actually I
treated
um
these are kind of interesting I did get
hit with a venmo request for that
experience no you did not do that
Jack and our 50 work for business
partners on the floor
it doesn't make sense yeah that's yeah
no I spent in total today uh I would
have paid Alex's Uber or whatever you
spent getting here
40 bucks 40 bucks
um but I guess it's a that's part of the
iced coffee or whatever to bring all the
equipment and Alex having Alex here
um so forty dollars plus 15 for sweet
Greens Plus seven bow but no so 15 30
plus 40 uh so 70 is how much I've spent
today but most of that is like I think
what we're getting to right here is he's
very frugal he still does like if we go
to a restaurant he will save the the
temporary utensils if he doesn't use
them he will that's just yeah he will
like that he will reuse his flosser like
several times several times
uh just my dad's a dentist I don't think
that's good your dad's a dentist though
uh you know I'm not the dentist but
whatever all right yeah you're not the
dentist though yeah
genuinely very cheap like like
definitely far more uh sorry not cheap
but Frugal far more frugal than I would
say probably anyone I've ever met so do
you and your fiance spend time together
yes uh but you know what we we are still
trying to figure some of it out I would
say I'd say in the beginning we really
had like this dedicated schedule where
it was like you know weekends and then
weekdays after like seven we had a very
uh regimented schedule and sometimes
like things will come up and it so now
we do our best usually like one day a
week dedicated to like just doing stuff
and then usually every weekday after
like eight I'm done or sometimes earlier
uh so we find that yeah that's good work
life balance is always good I always I
ask because
um because of Ashley and obviously that
we are we have a work-life balance you
know both and I'm just curious what
another couple does yeah and especially
as a YouTuber couple or I mean you as
someone who's a YouTuber with a
girlfriend yeah yeah
and a dog and a cat oh and a dog and a
cat yeah and a fish tank in a fish tank
you got your hands full the whole thing
so that's what makes traveling kind of
difficult because I get antsy over not
seeing the fish for like because things
yeah now I know it's different but the
fish tank like um I checked I checked
the parameters every day for my phone to
make sure you have a camera like you can
see the eye Joe you can I do yeah oh wow
do you have names for the fish uh Macy
does I don't okay that's his fiance you
know I'm also curious how you got into
YouTube I mean both you guys how you got
into like creating I just always want to
make YouTube videos and I just decided
one day after putting it off for years
that I was gonna film a video and put it
out there and make content that I
thought would be helpful that I wished I
could have seen and I loved it so much I
just continued and what was this uh
December of 2016 was when I posted my
first video and then I started posting
one to two times a week in January of
2017 and then it went to three times a
week I think in February or March like
pretty quick because I realized when I
was posting like once a week I'd get
like a certain amount of views and I
thought well let me do twice a week and
I did that night the view started to
actually like grow and I was like well
if I do three times a week and then I
just decided pretty quickly on that that
was like the perfect amount to grow yeah
I think you know YouTube's ever changing
so it's good to like look at you know
what you know the audience is you know
responding to so because I feel like
nowadays quality is really important
versus back in the day I feel like we
could get away with a lot of quantity
um but nowadays everyone has so many
options so you like yeah Tick Tock yeah
I was comparing it earlier there's so
many more people on the platform so that
like in the past let's just say there
would be one docus Style video a week
that would come out from like one
Creator I was like okay they get all the
views but everything else now is like up
for grabs yeah but now you have 10
creators each posting these insane docu
Style videos independently and so
there's one every single day uh so you
have to up your quality because everyone
else is yep um and there's more for
people to pick from so like you have to
be even more selective yeah for sure if
I can ask how big your operationally how
many people do you guys or do you work
you see like basically the whole team
here really okay Andrew back in Vegas
what about like editors and stuff
Andrew's back in Vegas Andrew and Alex
helps on the main Channel Alice is like
90 of the main Channel there's maybe the
occasional video that I'll just bang out
really quick
um
but that's it it's a really small team
and uh you know I think we gotta we're
talking about maybe hiring someone full
time to do guest Outreach who knows that
like that's their business is just like
linking people together with podcasts
yeah and like doing the media stuff so
we don't know that that well we don't
have this connection so yeah that's
someone that we think about maybe you
know bringing on the team yeah I feel
like a small team is good especially for
Content it becomes like I think a little
bit less genuine the more and more you
become big yeah so yeah I admire the
people who have really small teams and
like we we did Dr Mike the other night
and just seeing like she's just in his
apartment it was just really cool it's
just like him and two guys and they're
just all buddies and I I like that I
like that a lot cool well thanks man I
really appreciate it yeah thank you for
hosting us I love the playhouse
the other thing that I do want to
mention to you is that you can't you
guys can check me out Publications
somewhere in the description Kelly's got
his stuff linked down below thank you so
much for tuning in and until just
public.com
right you'll do it what is public.com